[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es das
persische ich habe mir ist muss mal
wieder ein persisches gericht her
wir machen persisches kebab das ist
typisch dass man da zum beispiel zu mag
und safran rein
aber ich erzähle euch gleich alles ganz
in ruhe ich habe jetzt hier meine kinder
hackfleisch diesmal habe ich nicht das
fettarme genommen
ich geb ich fang dir kann ich geb dir
jetzt zuallererst mal zwiebeln rhein und
die müsst ihr fein reiben
das ist ganz wichtig und anschließend
kommt auch noch knoblauch dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als nächstes geben wir den sack dazu
dafür muss ich erst mal gibt dann
schluck wasser dazu und dann mit zum
fleisch safran ist beim persischen
gerichten nicht wegzudenken wenn es
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig einerseits
hatte eigengeschmack und andererseits
hebt er auch noch den geschmack aller
zutaten die verwendet werden also
probiert es unbedingt aus ich gebe jetzt
hier noch salz dazu natürlich pfeffer
außerdem gehört zum persischen kebab
auch immer kurkuma und ganz wichtig
darauf nicht verzichten so mag also es
sich beim gewürzt mit rein geben und
dann schön kneten
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das fleisch ungefähr vier
minuten lang geknetet mit den händen die
könnte jetzt auch die bosnier mit ihr
habt das macht sie auch mit links jetzt
müsst ihr das einfach nur noch in den
ofen schieben
traditionell ist es so dass man das
grillt aufspießen aber wenn man hinter
grill deswegen machen sie zum ofen ihr
könnt sogar in der pfanne machen dann
einfach von beiden seiten aus braten
würde sogar auch gehen ich nehme jetzt
hier meine grillschale das ist keine
eigene kür schale sowie ihr sie
vielleicht kennt das ist eine die man
immer und immer wieder benutzen kann und
die nehme ich heute gibt er jetzt noch
einen bug bock drauf weil eben auch
gleich das fett vom fleisch austreten
wird einmal drauf geben
so und jetzt einfach ganz schön flach
andrücken
[Musik]
in die kleine griechische gebe ich jetzt
noch tomaten und tarot nie und dann will
ich das auch im backofen so das thema
kommt jetzt bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze in den vorgeheizten backofen
für circa 20 bis 22 minuten bis es
komplett gar ist
[Musik]
bei uns gibt es dazu jetzt reiß ich
mache dazu einfach basmatireis kurz
vorher ordentlich abspülen damit keine
stärke enthalten ist das ganze in öl so
ein bisschen am ersten und mit wasser
auffüllen und dann lass dir das ganz
einfach auf niedriger stufe köcheln das
ist gar ist und weil das eben dazu passt
mache ich jetzt auch noch so ein
bisschen optisch was mit safran und
natürlich auch geschmacklich dafür nimmt
er euch jetzt wieder safran tut's in den
mörser und dann kommt da ein bisschen
heißes wasser mit dazu
[Musik]
so anschließend färbt die einen teil des
reichs einfach mit dem safran wasser ein
und gibt das auf dem weißen reis und
fertig ist das also ich find das macht
auch noch mal optisch was her zieht
einfach schmackhafte aus so da könnte es
auch noch rosinen dazu finde ich auch
immer ganz lecker oder was ich auch sehr
lecker finden sind generell bären goji
beeren in welche getrockneten beeren
müsste einfach mal ausprobieren und oder
nüsse und gott ich liebe reißt
mindestens müssen wir eigentlich machen
ich werde jetzt ganz kurz zum ofen und
das kebab haus wurden dann zeige ich
euch wie ich alles sehr wäre jetzt dürft
ihr euch nicht wundern dass fleisch
schrumpft beim backen wegen des fed
anteil und jetzt schneidet ihr das
einfach in lange strenge und dann könnt
ihr das einfach alles komplett serviert
mit den tomaten mit der parodie mit reis
und gerne auch noch mit ein bisschen
joghurt und ich mache ganz am ende auch
noch mal ein bisschen zu mag obendrauf
durch darüber dass du das jetzt vor
ja genau
[Musik]
jetzt müsst ihr euch das ganze ja nur
noch schmecken lassen einen guten
appetit schaut in die video beschreibung
natürlich wie immer für alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben ansonsten solltet
ihr allerspätestens jetzt meinen kanal
abonnieren wenn ihr die ramadan reihe
nicht verpassen möchte jetzt gibt es den
ganzen monat lang orientalische rezepte
und wenn ihr vorschläge habt ein zwei
tage habe ich noch frei schreibt sie mir
jetzt hier unten in die kommentare was
ich unbedingt machen soll und dann sehen
wir uns wir haben es mit erzählt
schiffen ist eure keegan
[Musik]